Hutchins and Simon I want to start with
you because you guys have worked on so
many of these Wolverine and x-men films
at what point did was the decision made
that this would be kind of an ending
film of sorts for this character and how
scary of a prospect was that to even
consider that that really was something
that that Jim and Hugh authored as much
as anything else growing out of the last
one and and and and not that scary I
don't think at least not for me it
really was something that felt it it
longed to be told and and I think it's a
credit to to Jim's instincts and Hugh's
instincts and the collective I guess but
really led by Jim that that that was
where the character needed to go that's
where the story needed to go it was the
you know sort of the the part of the
journey that had been unfulfilled I
think for Hugh so it was something that
we were incredibly grateful to be able
to do and and something that I think we
were all incredibly excited that that we
were supported in being able to do and
do something that was as bold and and
see Jim's vision kind of fully realized
this way and Simon no pushback from any
suits no the studio was really
supportive I think we've been asked that
question the most into this part of the
process and the better story would be
that the studio pushed back and that we
had to fight them and but the truth is
they really respected really Hugh and
Jim's vision for the film I think if we
didn't have the movie star in the
director pushing forward it would have
been a little bit more complicated but I
think they saw that the movie needed to
feel provocative and different and fresh
and one of the ways we would do that
would be to end Hugh's tenure as this
character and so they were supportive of
it and and yet part of that candidly as
producers was that the budget of the
film to get an R rating
and to do something that bold was not
what it had been in the past and so we
made this movie for significantly
significantly less than we make the
mainland x-men movies and less than you
made your last Wolverine movie as well
Jim you have a great screenwriter Scott
Frank who did out of sight which is one
of my favorite movies of the last 20
years and so many other great things
where did this kind of Western feel come
from well the two of us have written
together on several movies and this one
as well and I think the Western feel
it's kind of funny because I whenever I
watch it you know as the press is kind
of taking over the Western thing
obviously from Shane and and many very
apt observations about my own taste and
the fact that happened to have made a
Western and maybe but it's also kind of
a noir film in the first act I actually
think but I think the two are very tied
I think noir films and westerns are kind
of like close cousins and the but the
vibe I mean Scott and I both share it's
why we work together so often I think we
share a real love for old movies and and
almost a pathological love for old
movies in the sense that we really are
trying to steer we really resist a lot
of modern tropes of filmmaking pretty
hard to the point of being pretty
stubborn and but that's the way we get
along and it's something that drives us
and it's not so much I mean we never
have time to get into this kind of stuff
but like westerns aren't guns and horses
and cabins and homesteaders there it's
the simplicity it's the westerns and
samurai films and there's there's a kind
of elegance to getting all the crap of
the crap the kind of logistical crap of
movies out of them and reducing it to
its essence struggle to live the
struggle to love the struggle for
freedom the elements are reduced to
their bare minimum how can you not love
a Western when you describe it that way
most of what people hesitate about when
you bring up a Western is they're
thinking some kind of Knott's Berry Farm
horrible
and of and that's mostly also television
westerns and kind of you know there was
a time when the comic-book movie you
know those and I would count myself
among them who feel like oh god is there
a night on television or I don't see a
comic-book character is there not is
there a weekend movie releases where I
won't see a comic book character there
was a time of 30 40 50 years ago where
I'm sure some similarly cantankerous
soul was going can I just turn on
Della's and not see a Western and I just
go to the movies and not see a Western
and what's happened is the Western the
shitty westerns have disappeared and the
great westerns have stayed and but still
I think people have a terrible
resistance to them because they see them
mainly as kind of varmint talk and
saloons and and that's all actually what
I mean I'm sure those there's a
wonderful writer of Bonanza in the
audience who I'm going to crush but it's
more what television did to the Western
than what the great what John Ford did
to the Western there isn't really much
varmint talk in in great American
western films that's something else
Pacha prior to this film Charles Xavier
as played by you had died on screen one
and a half times right like one yes once
maybe had you given up hope that you
would be asked to play this character
again or were you always like it's comic
books of course I'm coming back
well actors never give up hope yeah he
was obliterated by Jean Grey and it was
very uncomfortable no it actually was
very uncommon and then we assumed that
he must have died when those mechanical
monsters at the end of Days of Future
past finally broke into our central
control room there wasn't much hope left
there I think um but when the call came
hey is going to be a Wolverine movie and
they would like to talk to you about it
I was delighted because every part of
this
experience 17 years has been exciting
and stimulating and warm and funny and
crazy and then as word began to filter
down from the production that this was
going to be a different movie my
interest piqued and piqued and peeks and
then finally I went to talk to James and
a few minutes into the conversation he
learned I hadn't seen his script and you
did a lot of yelling I remember I was
impressed by the yelling you did bring
this quietly and I took it home and I
read it and what what excited me most
was not the scenes not the dialogue
initially but it was the stage direction
of the location where my first scene
took place because nothing in the past
of x-men had ever been set for me in
such a location it's so fun to see these
great scenes with you at Hugh and then
it's so wonderful to have this exciting
new addition of the character of Laura
played by Daphne Keane who I've been
researching because I'm just so
fascinated by her and I read that she is
the child of two actors her dad as a
British actor who's on the crown and
then her mom is a Spanish actor so how
did you find her when Scott and I
finished last pass on the script the we
had a very simple breakdown for what we
needed for the role of Laura which was
someone between 10 and 12 years old who
was an amazing actress physically
capable bilingual and of Latino descent
and the and so then the search went out
in South America Europe in the United
States obviously everywhere for this kid
you also couldn't have them read the
actual script because of the environment
we live in of secrecy and worry you have
to invent kind of this odd ten gentle
parallel universe audition piece for
them to do
which is really annoying for me and the
and but this tape came in one day from
London of young actress in Spain in
Madrid who would whose dad had recorded
this little two-minute iPhone movie with
her and I watch this thing and all I can
say is that I immediately knew there was
like two things new I knew it was her
she was going to be that I knew it was
just done but I also knew the movie
would be okay you know Scott and I had
written a three-legged stool essentially
and this guy's an incredible actor and I
made three movies two at that point with
Hugh Jackman and he's an incredible
actor so there's a certain amount of
stability and comfort you feel about
those two legs of the stool but then
this other creature was a complete
question mark and this tape just I can't
explain it other than to say that it
just it said I'm here and I can do it I
can't thank the four of you enough for
being here and for making a superhero
movie for grown-ups
congratulate welcome and well done